Ouais
[Musique]
non non
parce que
ensemble
[Musique]
communes
et
Non
[Musique]
et c'est que l'avenir de l'action
dans l'histoire de l'église
vécu une semaine sainte comme cette semaine
en raison de la pandémie, puis
nous devons juste suivre les règles
que le gouvernement nous donne pour être
enfermés nous ne pouvions pas nous ne pouvions pas
sortir
[Musique]
beaucoup de fidèles en ce moment dans la semaine sainte
Ils ont besoin de se rapprocher de Dieu et
ils le font à travers
fêtes que nous transmettons
les prêtres à travers les filets
et aussi cette opportunité de
avouer dans leurs véhicules comme cela a été
pour les fidèles un signe que le
l'église est avec eux
[Musique]
sacrement en même temps
peut récolter parce que da vinci
Je suis un gomme-nous et confessionnel
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
les gens
Ouais